[Музика]
я невидимі вороги Люсія з Клейса
Данхема з долини, ідеолог якої
ще гей Nucci
yay negatory yeah presume wanaka do
remove classy more girl walk on presume
уникнути помилок Kowalski ввести Noatak мій
огляд двічі a bush  Нікарагуа
так парасолька res замок діалог
напівневидимий вітамін Плісскен і
Вісконті підходять до президента для
[музики]
привіт всім мене звуть Наталія школа
пора уроків англійської мови
починати
я хотів би сьогодні привітати моїх дорогих
учнів привіт я Тоні привіт  Наталія,
добре, як ти сьогодні, я добре, а ти,
я чудовий, дуже дякую, тому
сьогодні ми продовжимо розмову про
Інтернет о, мені подобається Інтернет, добре
, а ти любиш користуватися Інтернетом,
давайте почнемо, щоб ви почули звук
і я хотів би, щоб ти вгадав, що це
добре,
я теж буду плакати, так що слухай і скажи мені, що
ти теж слухай, і ми подивимося, хто
швидше, я розірваний, якщо ти
можеш вгадати звук, що це,
можливо, це"  s storm, можливо, добре і все
інше так, можливо, це механічні звуки
добре, я допоможу вам, тому давайте
подивимося на заголовки новин, і в
новинах ви можете вгадати, ймовірно, пристрій, про
який згадувалося, добре, тож давайте
подивимося на новину  всі
вони приблизно один і той самий пристрій,
так, це, мабуть, допомогло б мені, але мм-хм,
якщо не так, однакові слова, які починаються
на букву R Я допоможу тобі
ах це вакуум так це Роберт
Кролик пилосос так  Роберт пилососить, тож
сьогодні ми поговоримо про роботів
уууууууууууууууууууууууу,ти коли-небудь мали справу з роботами справжніми
роботами справжньою, яка схожа на
людину, будь-
який робот так, ти знаєш, у мене є багато
роботів у моєму домі, я дуже люблю роботів,
так, це дивовижно, так що
подивіться, давайте подивимося саме на ці
заголовки, наші роботи сидять
номер два маленькі повсякденні помічники, що
робить хороший робот-пилосос
майбутнє, і воно приходить на вашу
кухню номер чотири робот-вчителі
, бути чи ні  e та останній найкращий
робот пилососить, щоб зробити брудну роботу за
вас, тож скільки роботів уявіть собі, що
ви думаєте відповідно до заголовків,
чи це те саме Ні Ні, можливо, троє,
можливо, три з них так, правильно, коли
ви бачите вас  можна побачити робота-пилосос так
так
О, робот-прибиральник-прибиральник, тож, ймовірно, він
може допомогти на кухні,
мабуть, і ми бачимо ще один робот-
пристрій, тож єдиний робот, якого ми не можемо
побачити тут відповідно до заголовків, що
ви думаєте, я думаю, що це  робот
вчитель так, ми точно не бачимо
робота вчителя ні так добре, давайте
спочатку почнемо з цих пристроїв добре, і ми
зосередимося на роботі-пилососі, чи є він
у вас вдома, ні, у мене немає, але у мого друга
є один хороший, тому  Я називаю його Сіною, і
перед тим, як ми дивимося, як він працює, давайте
обговоримо слова, виглядайте
зручно, корисно, недорогий портативний і розумний.
Хм, чи знаєте ви всі ці слова, давайте
обговоримо, щоб було спочатку одне, що
це означає, зручно, коли я думаю, що
це  коли він зможе використовувати його своїми руками
або це маленький добре, подивіться
зручно та корисно, вони
насправді синоніми о, це те саме, що ви можете
сказати, це корисно, це зручно, це
абсолютно правильно, добре, але коли ви використовуєте
його своїми руками, це зручно, тому ваше
визначення було в порядку  також добре, давайте
перейдемо до низьких витрат, що це означає, що
він дешевий, так дешевий, він не
коштує багато, він дуже доступний, він
портативний, він маленький, ви можете брати
його з собою куди завгодно,
так, правильно і розумно  розумний
, я можу сказати, якщо ви думаєте про розумний
і мудрий, ймовірно, розумний буде
посередині добре, дозвольте мені намалювати клієнта для
вас, тож якщо ми поставимо його на лінію, то ось
розумний, добре,
це добре, але знову ж таки це  не те, що у
верхньому правому куті це розумно, і тоді у нас
є мудрий,
добре, тому розумний буде щось
середнє, тому це, безумовно, більше
ніж розумно, але це недостатньо розумно, щоб
бути таким мудрим, добре, так що давайте далі
, подивимося, це моє  старший ось
як це працює
вентилятор  tastic Мені подобається це
так чудово  тому що це робот
правильно, це людина, яка використовує
прикметники, тож це зручно чи корисно, як
ви думаєте, я думаю, так так, чи можете ви
дати мені повне речення, будь ласка, так, я
думаю, так, я думаю, що ваш старший робот
дійсно корисний і зручний, добре що  про
інших портативний розумний недорогий я думаю, що
це справді портативний робот Сіна
досить портативний гарне дякую,
що ви думаєте про ціну
, недорогий це робот чи ні мені здається,
що цей робот насправді не низький  -вартість
мм-хм, тож якщо ми подумаємо, якщо ви
порівняєте, наприклад, цього робота,
робот пилососить, скажімо, робот-вчитель,
що буде дорожче,
цей або робот-вчитель, я думаю, що
робот-вчитель буде дорожчим
добре, так, я згоден, і якщо ми подивимося
на цього конкретного старшого робота, я називаю
його старшим таким ім’ям, тому він
дуже маленький, ви сказали, що він портативний, він
дуже зручний, корисний і дуже
доступний, тому я можу сказати, що це низька вартість,
це не так  не коштує багато, хм, кожен
я думаю, що кожен може собі це
дозволити  Ви уявляєте, що
мені потрібно добре заряджати акумулятор,
і він повертається до зарядного пристрою, але якби
Сіна був моїм роботом, він би, ймовірно, сказав, що
ви повинні почистити його самостійно
, це
добре, якщо я не помиляюся, ви можете використовувати
програму, і ви можете вводити  у
фразах, що ви хочете, щоб ваш робот
говорив з вами дійсно розумно,
це розумно, давайте перейдемо далі, щоб сам робот
ми могли використовувати слова зручний корисний
недорогий портативний smarts будь-які роботи так
і давайте обговоримо, наприклад, робота
вчитель добре добре так  це йде  g щоб бути
низькою вартістю, ми вже вирішили, що це
не буде дешево, так це
буде дуже дорого, а
як щодо портативного розумного, корисного, зручного
критерію Я думаю, що корисно та зручно
, напевно, так, ні, але вчителі були б
дійсно корисними, тому що це допомагає
люди мм-хм, а що я можу
сказати про портативних, я думаю, що вони
не будуть справді портативними, ви не можете
покласти свого робота вчителя в кишеню,
просто сходіть на іспит, але це була б гарна
ідея, але якщо ви хочете  побачите справді
хорошого і схожого на людину вчителя-робота, він
ніколи не був би портативним, добре, і
це напевно було б дуже розумно
так, погодьтеся, тому що нам потрібен вчитель
для слів для освіти правильно, тому нам потрібно
трохи вчитися, безумовно, вчитель
повинен бути розумним і  правильно відповісти на всі наші
запитання так добре, давайте рухаємося далі,
для вас є завдання. Я хочу, щоб ви
створили свій пул прикметників для
опису роботів або гаджетів, будь ласка, візьміть
аркуш паперу і спробуйте слова,
і через десять секунд ми  Ми збираємося разом перевіряти,
тож поки наші студенти
пишуть свої прикметники, ми також
створимо наш пул, ви не проти,
давайте зробимо це добре, тож ходімо далі, у нас
уже є
розумний портативний важіль, зручний корисний
недорогий, чи можете ви дати мені інші
прикметники  гарний вигляд, гарний вигляд,
це ми описували робота,
гарний робот, що ще спочатку швидко
допомогло б у безнадійному, корисному світлі,
як добре, добре одне з моїх улюблених слів
, коли я розмовляю зі старшим, я описую як
милий милий, він милий,
добре, це  добре, також ви згадали,
що робот-вчитель може бути дорогим, тому
робот може бути недорогим або дорогою ціною,
він більше схожий на людину,
як ви знаєте, як людина, як людське життя,
людина як так, як людина, тому що добре,
що ще, ймовірно, щось цікаве
слова правильно, це також можливо
цікаво, і якщо ви подивитеся на щось
і вам справді це подобається, це
так сильно, що ви скажете о, вау, це
дивовижно дивовижно,
правда, ви вражені дивовижно
добре, добре  у вас є список ваших
прикметників, підготуйтеся, ми збираємося використати
їх за мить, і ми йдемо далі, тому,
коли ми говоримо про роботів або будь-які
новини, які ми бачимо в Інтернеті, ми можемо
відреагувати, висловивши свою власну думку правильно,
тому якщо ви  подивіться щось, що ви кажете,
перш за все дуже популярні фрази я
думаю, що я думаю, що це дорого я думаю, що
це мило, що ще ми можемо сказати
мені подобається добре
все ще я вірю, що бачу вас так, на
мою думку, добре, я б сказав, що це так
дуже популярні фрази, і ви вже
їх знаєте, давайте дізнаємося щось нове, але
перед цим давайте потренуємося з Сіною, тож
як ми можемо описати старший, ми використовуємо ці
прикметники та фрази, щоб висловити
думку, наприклад, я думаю, що
старший не дорогий, що ви можете сказати  про
старшого
Я вважаю, що sinner дійсно корисний робот,
молодець, а що щодо вас, яку
ціну ви б використали, моя улюблена, на мій
погляд, Сіна швидкий, а останні чотири, які
ви хочете, на мій погляд, старший, на мій погляд, не
дуже добрий робот, схожий на людину  добре, давайте
рухатися далі і давайте вивчати нові фрази, щоб
висловити нашу думку, подивіться на цю
емоцію, то що ви можете сказати, як ви можете
це висловити будь-які ідеї я сказав так,
трохи божевільний, трохи, але ти
шалено закоханий ти справді  подобається, тобі це
дуже подобається, тож як ти можеш сказати, що цей
погляд вау, це вражаюче,
повторюй за мною вау, це вражає,
тепер твоя черга,
вау, це вражає, і знову вау
, це вражає
добре, давайте йти далі, це навпаки,
так, добре, так що вам не подобається  це мені не
подобається добре і подивіться, чоловіче, я не
вражений
хм, чоловіче, я не вражений, чи можеш ти повторити,
будь ласка, чувак, я не вражений і твоя
черга, чоловік, я не вражений і ще
раз, чоловіче, я  Я не дуже вражений,
тому подивіться, будь ласка, почуйте
вражаюче, тому що це вражає,
але коли ви говорите про себе, будь ласка,
пам'ятайте це, я НЕ вражений настільки
вражаючим, коли ми говоримо
про речі мм-хм або дії або
ситуацію і коли  ми говоримо про
себе вражені  мм-хм добре, добре,
давайте
продовжуємо, це круто і дивовижно, ти щойно
здогадався про моє обличчя ха-ха, це
цікаве, це круто,
добре, ти можеш повторити це, це круто,
добре, і твоя черга
, це круто, добре, і ще раз
це круто,
добре, ідеально, навпаки, ти  шокований
я допоможу тобі так я в порядку
я впевнений, що це жахливо це жахливо, тому
ти шокований тобі це не подобається це
може бути таким жахливим це також
синонім жахливого, так що це жахливо
це жахливо  фантастично, а тепер твоя
черга
, це жахливо і знову це жахливо
ідеально, тепер у нас є робот-старший, і у нас
є новина, що найкращий робот-
пилосос виконує брудну роботу за вас, тож
що ви можете сказати, щоб висловити свою думку
про старшого, це круто  добре, добре, я
не буду говорити, вау, це вражає,
тому що я не вражений повністю, але я
не можу сказати, що це жахливо, варум, давайте підемо
зі мною, я скажу, ма, я не
вражений,
добре, ми можемо зіграти в цього Далека  ще раз
подивіться, що це робот, якого він збирається
допоможу тобі з брудним словом на
кухні вау, це круто приємно ммм, я не
вражений
, це добре, практикуй ці фрази,
бачивши речі у вашому домі, давайте
йти далі, подивіться більше новин, ми
вже обговорювали це на наших перших
уроках,
тож давайте  revisie Я впевнений, що ви
пам'ятаєте, що
ніхто не керує Алекс автобус
перевозить пасажирів по місту
ваша думка вау, це вражаюче
фантастично Дякую Антоне, давайте
подивимося ще на одну новину, але для вас немає помічників,
їх листи надійшли
доставляє посилки задоволеним клієнтам, що
ви можете сказати, я не дуже хороший, це не
те, що автобус без водія
для нас більш цікавий, так, це
більш вражаюче, давайте рухатися далі, тепер
ваша черга сказати, а потім ми
відповімо на  ти Антон, робот на приймальні,
вітаємо гостей в універмагі добре,
а тепер Антон, це жахливо, ти не
хочеш говорити з Роландом о, я не хочу, щоб
Роберт вітав мене, добре, якщо
робот буде людиною  -як для мене
це нормально, я прийму це, але якщо
робот буде дійсно роботом і буде
говорити зі мною так, я не вражений
і мені це не подобається, я б не прийняв,
давайте перейдемо до наступної інформації
щілина взаємодіє з віртуальним світом за допомогою
віртуальної реальності Джим Я думаю, що це
вражаюче, молодець, і останній
гнучкі ремінці смартфона навколо вашого
зап'ястя, як годинник, подивіться, це
зображення гнучкого смартфона,
який гарний, класний, добре, добре, чи це
круто приємно бачити, що ми вже створили нову
фразу для вас добре, тож у нас є всі ці
пристрої, про які ми згадували сьогодні,
без водія, автобус, намальований робот-партійник
віртуальний дорогоцінний камінь гнучкі смартфони робот-
прибиральник робот-кухар або робот-вчитель
робот-кухар це оболонка робота
, для якого готує  добре, то як ви можете
описати цих роботів, використовуючи
прикметники мм-хм, що ви можете сказати, ви
можете використовувати фрази, які ми згадували, я
думаю, що я вірю
в свою думку, як це, а потім ви
додаєте  прикметники інформація про
роботів Я вважаю, що робот-кухар добре,
дійсно корисний робот на кухні
фантастика, згодні ви чи ні, давайте рухатися
далі, на мій погляд,
Роберт прибиральник дійсно милий робот, як
ми згадували раніше мм-хм добре
я вважаю, що  робот на ресепшн
дуже схожий на людину робот гарно ідеально
дякую я так хвилююсь і хвилююся я просто
відпочиваю, ти можеш сказати так, я справді
трохи напружений, немає стресу, ти можеш розслабитися
для вас ви можете використовувати власні прикметники,
щоб описати цих роботів, і ви можете виконати
це завдання як додаткове домашнє завдання, ми рухаємося
далі, і є завдання, щоб ви
запам'ятали роботів, і я хочу, щоб ви оцінили їх
від найменш корисних до марних
ви  не потрібно це, щоб допомогти вам, і номер
вісім є найкориснішим, ви можете здатися,
що ви не можете жити без нього добре, у вас
є 20 секунд, щоб зробити рейтинг, а
потім ми обговорюємо разом, добре,
тому Антон, я хотів би, щоб ви оцінили
роботи для студентів  чи пам’ятаєте ви
їх трохи добре, дозвольте мені допомогти вам
робот учитель робот шеф-кухар Роберт прибиральник
добре, а потім був дрон, який
був гнучкий смартфон, який був
без водія БОТИ,
що був наступний віртуальний тренажерний зал і робот на
ресепшн, добре, тому Антон, будь ласка,
запишіть свій власний  список, і ми
перевіримо вдруге, готово.
лайк, а потім
нам сподобається добре номер два для
мене, на мою думку, добре, це гнучкий
смартфон, навіщо вони потрібні, у
нас важкий так, саме наступний
, наступний - віртуальна команда, добре, я
думаю, тому чому  Ви б взяли ці
окуляри на голові, щоб робити віджимання,
просто робіть віджимання, чувак, це все, і
я не впевнений, що це допоможе вашому
тілу,
я маю на меті покращити свій стан
правильно краще піти в спортзал
Джейм, добрий номер  четвертий я думаю, що
це посередині це не дуже
корисно марно, але це не дуже корисно
на сьогодні, просто корисно так, це
автобус без водія, добре, це може покращити деякі
ситуації з рухом, можливо, але, можливо,
ні, тому що у нас немає інших
автомобілів без водія  вулиці
погоджуються, і ви пам'ятаєте, щоб
зменшити новини про автобус без водія, у
нас була аварія з таксі, тому це також може
бути небезпечним так, ніхто, я маю на увазі,
все було в безпеці,
але знову була незначна аварія,
так що номер п'ять я  поставити
туди пилосос добре робот-прибиральник робот-прибиральник
так добре, тому що ви не можете прибрати свою
кімнату самостійно погодьтеся, але ви не
дуже хочете, це може заощадити деякий час так,
для роботи англійською правильно, давайте рухатися
далі,
на мою думку, добре, це має  бути роботом-
кухарем хорошим, тому що
я не люблю готувати більше, ніж прибирати будинок, я бачу, і
це корисніше для мене добре
для мене це навпаки я люблю готувати,
але я не люблю прибирання добре, давайте
перейдемо до наступного оголошення  rone drone
добре, тому що, перш за все, ви можете знімати
дуже гарні відео я бачу нашу планету наші
міста з пташиного виду так, я згоден,
це дивовижно, я був би вражений
і найкориснішим і найкориснішим
так, але номер один для мене  добре, це
вчитель-робот, вчитель-робот, добре, що
ви можете сказати про робота-вчителя, що
збирається робити, це буде вивчати навчання, навчати
вас, це навчить вас, і мені потрібно,
щоб хтось мене добре навчив, тому що ви бачите, що
я роблю багато помилок, коли говорю  і
ти не можеш впоратися з цим, і я думаю, що
вчитель з гуми допоміг би мені більше і
краще, я бачу так, тому що я тут, я
не можу піти з тобою до тебе, але якщо у
тебе є робот, він може розмовляти з тобою і
покращуйте свої помилки,
не хвилюйтеся, ваша англійська гарна, не
хвилюйтеся про це,
тому тепер у вас є
три списки рейтингу, тож це
список Антона, подивіться на мій список, і у
вас є власні списки, тож давайте порівняємо
їх і не думайте, що  робот
портье найменш корисний я думаю,
що віртуальний  Джим, а як щодо тебе, що
твій номер один, номер два в моєму списку
намальовано, і не думаю, що малюнок
є досить корисним, що ти вважаєш
корисним, найменш корисним чи найбільш
корисним, давайте подивимося
десь посередині моє  номер п'ять
і шість - це робот-кухар і автобус без водія.
Антонія має робота-кухаря і робота-
прибиральника, а що щодо вас, у
вас є інший варіант або той самий,
а номер восьмий у нас той самий робот-
вчитель, так добре зроблено, що щодо вас, як
ви думаєте, вчитель проблеми
Я впевнений, що ви так думаєте,
тож давайте перейдемо далі, настав час вікторини,
і це зазвичай невеликий тест
добре, добре, ви зробите з нами, запишіть свої
відповіді, а потім ми разом перевіримо,
тому виправте примітку.
вражаюче подивіться на картинку додайте смайли
правильно чи не правильно Браво добре
наступний чоловік це круто ні це не
правильно так що має бути правильно
чоловік це забуто я не вражений
браво чоловік я не вражений якщо це знову
чоловік я  не вражений, і ти перетворишся на
ідеального чоловіка, я не вражений
, це жахливо, подивіться на картинку ні
, це невірно добре, що має бути
правильним один вау, це круто, добре, добре
, це круто, добре, о, твій варіант, це
добре, круто, настав час для
домашнього завдання  тож подумайте про роботів, яких ви
б хотіли винайти,
і напишіть про них свій власний параграф, на
жаль, є дзвіночок, і нам
потрібно припинити урок, тому
дуже дякую за урок Антоне і
до наступного разу до побачення на віллі Cali opener
на  поблизу Вашингтона ефективно пляж
вчора
так над моїм наймолодшим буде це не ключ
або добре циклічний Боніта король побажав
елемент аборт сказати, що ви показали під час
перевороту де Люсія атаки бюлетень повідець накум
інший західний так біміні емоційний
удар чіти в DOMA вона робить Інтернет
пакує кожен актив янгольський Петровський
хоч синім поясом іди мого розуму
[Музика]
ти